we do a thing here called feelings no
facts
natural segments ben shapiro has facts
don't care about your feelings we have a
feelings don't care about your facts
okay so these are a couple of the tweets
from uh what is her name ashley ashley
marie preston marie preston some of
those tweets let's see if we can get
them what site is this go to the the
these are the crazier ones are the
multiple what this is uh opindia.com
very reputable yeah yeah say some [ __ ]
ricky
all right we're going to need two other
sources for you to be okay with this one
that's the real thing i've checked
multiple sources okay let's see let's go
asian hoes act like they won't get
karate chop they [ __ ] throat
is this hoe staring at me mind your
beeswax it's not too bad
it's not too bad hit that next one yeah
latino and asian businesses need to stop
being rude you're latino i'm i'm
triggered okay uh they need to stop
being rude and [ __ ] disrespectful and
i know it's a lot to ask in california
but speak [ __ ] english oh [ __ ]
there's problems oh that's crazy
that's what you're allowed to tell
people to speak english in america no
that's wrong it's
it i mean
i think it's pretty crazy it's america
you're allowed to do whatever the [ __ ]
you want should we cancel her
um
it's not my jurisdiction bro all right
fair enough you're handling this quite
well yeah i know what else is going well
we've got you in the rapids right now
well guess what buddy okay i've got a
whole press team behind me let's keep
going
netflix is like if they say trans just
say no comment
it's hbo oh that's right uh
does hbo care about that what
hbo has been [ __ ] dope i love working
with them okay
i [ __ ] with hbo
i'm running back game of thrones right
now and i just want to know they're
doing their due diligence with you
in what way i got the update i got a
reminder
oh i didn't put it down to save because
i was running a little experiment i was
like are they gonna know
that i would like this special i'm a
comedian how much do they know about me
just for me watching the shows are they
gonna suggest you know what i mean
because if i go save to watch
then i don't know if they're doing their
due diligence with the people that
subscribe and yesterday i got the thing
that makes me very happy there we go
brother brother so they're doing their
thing okay another damn asian almost hit
me while crossing what the [ __ ] is with
y'all
and your damn vehicles i have an idea
i don't know where the rest of it is
what is what is what is her position
like is this hr
this asian n-word in subway got a fat
ass
he almost looked like a [ __ ] from
behind that's fire that's okay it's
almost a compliment in a way
people say that about me at times
just
just broke my phone on this asian
bitch's head i have asian friends well
this is a problem some [ __ ]
weirdo sometimes you can't be assaulting
people like that well you mean you broke
your phone on their head that's crazy
ain't it well that seems like a
continuation it looks like wait i can we
see another source
i just can't be having opinions on
here's what what she said she said this
was a time before she was openly trans
she was on meth she was addicted to meth
addiction and then she was like lashing
out yeah now there's also a tweet that
you know you can be addicted to meth and
get a good job
yeah like this is talk about that
yeah she was one of uh elizabeth
warren's like surrogates or something
like she was somehow on elizabeth warren
staff that's when this came up the first
time so this has come up before
you